and we're live are we are we I think so
I mean a lot it says we're we're alive I
love to be alive we're alive is that
zombie podcast I remember that I show
that to you Oh was that them you're
alive we are allies foes apology it's
like it you don't like a pug its daring
it's a podcast of kazan bones what oh
yeah Zamboni sigh you said Sam bones I
thought Zamboni's realize what you were
doing but in my tired state I my mind
just went straight to you know what
cleaning up the ice oh yeah keeping the
ice maintain somebody get me a Zamboni
and clean my [ __ ] up Oh simple we wanna
hope you do this oh no this is hard mom
that's what adult life feels like it's
like the more adult you like we like the
more your internal whiny kid voice just
grows and consumes you I don't know if
it's even like the voice but just it the
raw feeling of that does does become
more prevalent oh yeah it's like you
don't even have to say it out loud as
yourselves are saying it for years yeah
so welcome to take a snow day guess does
really starting out in a jovial note
today I feel like we're already like I
don't want to say looking forward to but
we're anticipating what we're going to
attempt to do with this episode yeah I
mean you know I my name is Aaron my name
is Jerry and we are your Sherpas on this
voyage into dankness yes let's let's get
ready to get sad as hail yeah this is
her depression episode I guess I mean
not its art
I mean we DANC gets to sink its Jane
gets down then gets down here but that
could be like a bougie ass episode yeah
I've been getting down yeah I've been
getting down in Tunes all week it's like
the one bright spot like consistently
this week was new tune yeah I gotta I
gotta catch up on the tunes I want to
get into I was jamming out to some
podcast this week ok hey man I mean you
know the the flow of speech can be just
as musical no time which casts man what
you listen it I found a cool podcast
remember when we we once got into a
conversation where I was like someone
should write a book that just all the
things that are wrong with the human
brain yeah well there's a podcast and i
think one obviously man what would that
book even be called I think this popped
into my head and it is the title of the
podcast oh sure it is the the you are
not so smart podcast it is basically
just quirky things about human
psychology and sociology all discussed
in podcast form I'm a write this [ __ ]
down yeah it's it's pretty neat i've
checked out uh just a few of their
episodes they did one where they were
talking about learned helplessness and
yeah they went into just how that was
discovered in you know in the in the
laboratory experiments that gave birth
to that realization and how it's been
observed in people and you know things
like that um you did down its academia
in your spare time mm-hmm I'm trying to
do that man but you know the grind way
lays without I don't know I guess maybe
just like I think maybe that's part of
the problems with college because you
get so focused on oh I gotta do this
essay and throwing this test you get the
college sadly ends up kind of becoming a
grind like high school where it's like I
love to sit and just actually learn
about this [ __ ] but I have to just you
know memorize figures and facts and
throw in whatever
not actually interact with this material
well yeah it's like I got it I gotta
satisfy somebody else criterion like I
would have loved to have just gone to
college where all we have to do is just
like sit and talk about the topics and
then from there I get graded on that but
that wouldn't be so that would be very
hard for a teacher or professor to
measure well I guess it would be
pass/fail and then you just judge I'm
like you know conviction and
demonstrational you know of mastery of
mastery and you have to have like
brilliant ass teachers yeah you would
have to have your such wide ranges of
expertise yeah you would have to
basically you would have to have a
school where there's just a bunch of
really good teachers and no
administration really yeah yeah no no
administration and no like no like weird
district numbers to keep up with
national averages and [ __ ] like yeah you
know basically like like ratings it's
kind of like ratings are for TV is just
like those are your rating for your
school yeah like I don't always tell us
that stuff at least it I don't remember
if we got this in high school even in
elementary like we are such and such
school in the district or the district
as some kind of motivator for us to do
better on those standardized tests yeah
it's like why why do we want to do well
on this school so this whole gets a
higher number we hate this place and by
the time that matters for you will be
out of here yeah it's like you know so I
guess I know I I want to teach us to get
paid with like what it's weird that I
should be like you know driving up your
average so you can make more tuition
money yeah it's like I want the teachers
to get paid but it's like why is the
buck getting passed on the teachers in
that way cuz they seem like really
[ __ ] overworked yeah well especially
I don't know how teachers in in other
parts the world are but it seemed like
an affair I've never met a teacher in
America maybe in the college level like
if you get a professor with like a real
nice tenure like like that dudes relaxed
but like most teachers are a little
harried uh their their cars usually you
know not of us
few weeks out from from good washing and
and you know they always look a little
flustered like that's why the teacher I
imagine in my mind's eye like the only
teachers I knew of that didn't have that
going on where people were teachers and
Phillips will that were like yeah you
know I I teach here and I'm an adjunct
here but really i'm out i'm i'm teaching
here to pay my bills while I'm out of
here to actually do my stuff yeah um and
you know I've never encountered one that
wasn't still bringing their a-game to
the teaching you know scenario because
just you know they care about the actual
subject they they made the subject
they're like both teaching it and doing
it nuts that's chill well I wonder
perhaps if it so that's I mean I'm sure
any any teacher you know any any uh
faction of knowledge like you'll find
somebody who's very passionate about
teaching it but I almost wonder if like
in the arts people are more willing to
want to teach well you know it's like
you could easily kind of be like well I
know chemistry I guess I could just
teach it no versus like man I love
pottery I'm gonna teach these young
folks and do this because I just [ __ ]
love it yeah cuz you're feeding into
that excitement you got when you were
first entering that world and yes it's
like if you're a film professor like you
still kind of get to hang out and talk
about movies you just expect stuff the
people that you're talking to yeah now I
guess um I guess that's that's more or
less why I'm into a bunch of like pseudo
academic pursuit Oh educational podcast
just because you know i miss that i miss
people like talking deeply at length
about a given topic about a given
subject well there was this was the
really sad realization for me once i got
done with school finally after so long
was like I got done with school and all
of a sudden I was like man I just want
to read books and learn [ __ ] yeah
exactly right and it's it's just kinda I
don't know that it is sad to me that
that should happen because you know it's
I was never a great stew
then I never really loved school like I
would occasionally find things to be
interested in but no you know I didn't
for some reason the hunger for learning
didn't kick in quite that way until i
was done with that's also at school it's
like it's at school you know there's the
idea of like you you go to school and
you pick up the catalog and just this
big menu of all these classes that you
can take in all these things you can
learn about it sounds [ __ ] badass but
then it's like if I sign on to learn
this thing I'm going to be tied up for
four or five months well yeah and I'm
going to have to pay another X thousand
dollars down the line and then there's
also just the you know the general kind
of you like you'll read about a class
and it sounds really awesome and there's
that reversal thing where it's like
usually the classes that sounded dry
we're actually kind of cool in some of
the classes that said a really awesome
war kind of not as much and sillier you
almost you know not only do you have
just this tome of options but also you
know you never know what you're gonna
actually drive on what is going to be
taught in a way that suits your learning
habits I I know that I had a very
interesting um not an interesting
experience like when I was at my JC
where was I got into an intro to
philosophy class and this was like way
way way you know first year or two of my
undergrad on it was like oh this is so
cool intro to philosophy and then the
professor turned out to be insane laughs
oh boy and a bad person oh and so I was
like wow this [ __ ] blows same and a
bad person like you know um you remember
Paul Bettany character from from The Da
Vinci Code yes I shudder to to what to
ask where this this comparison has take
this book this philosopher this
philosophy professor was a bit like that
Oh like like so Catholic he is trying to
hurt you
mmm and very much energy a scene oh yeah
very much tried resting with a smile a
very creepy twisted like Kevin Bacon
character smile was doing a lot of like
gross preaching from you know the podium
and go theology Department dude yeah
yeah not even but it was very it was
very kind of creepy and unnerving and so
I dropped that class I ended up in a I
ended up taking an online version of of
that same class with a different
professor and it's like online you don't
quaint you don't get the same effect
because you can't really have that full
on discussion in that same way yeah nice
experience I ever had with offline was
one of those hybrid classes what was
like we meet on Tuesday computer on
Thursday yeah you know cuz then he kind
of got both and there was still
accountability because like straight up
online classes I never did well at ya so
that was um yeah so I mean that that
kind of made it frustrating because it
was you know I was like I I wanted to
get into this I wanted to learn about
this thing I want to learn about this
thing at the intricate college level and
I kind of got shortchanged out of that
but now I have the wide wonderful world
of YouTube channels about philosophy and
podcasts about philosophy and there's a
lot of it let me tell you oddly enough
yeah there's a you know all you gotta
know is which rock to look under yeah a
wealth of you know a squirmy imagination
bugs yeah intellect bugs so I took a
class for presser I remember this
vividly name was Professor tubs and he
taught us how to make flag as rubs spice
profiles marinade marinades glazes the
chutneys whatever you want professor
tubs had that she professed Frank asked
tubs bringing you tandoori seasoning if
you
want it and his tandoori was this year
oh yeah sorry I had to slip that in
there goes some good [ __ ] is dope so
today I guess we're basically doing an
audio let's play of oh this is gonna be
an interesting experiment why don't you
because you brought this to to to the
proverbial tables well for a few things
because well did you find this on a
podcast no I found out about this just
on the internet basically um we're we're
going to be doing a an audio let's play
in essence of a a text adventure game in
a sense I thought averett kind of
adventure yeah well it's basically a
text adventure so that makes it prime
for doing you just audio it's not like
you guys are missing out on on you know
visuals just a shot of a screen
occasionally scrolling your face and
it's the way to big reaction I feel like
if someone's gonna do a let's play of a
text adventure you want the you would
have to flip the script where the
gameplay footage is small in their face
is big or just make them work glasses so
you can see the text on their son watch
you get two boxes with a slightly
different view of my god I love people
doing I love people doing um like goofy
photos of them staring at computer
screens in capote it's like the
whatever's on the photo whatever is on
the computer screen you don't see the
computer screen you see an angle on
their face with reflective sunglasses
and you see what's on the computer
screen their sunglasses and it's like I
thought well where was just like this
this grumpy looking dude and the caption
was like yeah mom I'm doing my homework
and reflected in his sunglasses were
just a microsoft word document with the
words gay porn in giant letters yeah
moms do about word I want to see this
photograph it's making me happy I saw
another one where was a guy like with
this intense like look on his face and
he was very clearly trying to give like
the 90s like matrix hacker look and
reflection in the sunglasses were
were the words of world mean database
and the caption was I mean I do like
this subcategory yeah I just want to do
everything and reflective a theater yeah
so we're going to be we're gonna be
playing a depression quest the
impression where it gets you won't get
sad as hell you want to get depressed
off your ass so he couldn't go spread
you ass with viruses yo by precedes so
you want better if we got bathroom
they're called your past let's just
recite that SNL bit why don't we got
this that's what the show will
eventually become in us you know
acapella reciting you know from our
favorite bits from other community media
yeah all right the guardian the
guardian' LaGuardia LaGuardia was for a
tad depression quest.com it's already a
shortcut there we go here we do
depression quest by zoe quinn um so uh
we will we'll skip the the intro but
basically depression quest just talks
about yet it's a bit of a disclaimer
this game is not supposed to be
indicative of everyone's experience with
depression it's not supposed to be a
medically you know it sounds was to be a
diagnostic tool a hundred percent
medically accurate you had a depression
p oh just a chain of people like they're
just like a butt like this dr stitching
people with their heads on each other's
shoulders just kinda like sushi you
together asked to sadness she's
stitching people so it's like you're
just kind of like leaning against each
other and dislike morose humph yeah was
all kind of leaning like it like like
sad dominoes yes not not the pizza dough
no sad dominoes is a thing of the past
yeah cuz they're just dominos message
that's for difference I feel like sad
dominoes
be a novelty Twitter account that
someone should make that would be great
sad Domino's add dominoes just like just
just the corporate entity it doesn't
even have to sound like it's like from
an employee just just like knows we have
new sauce it's okay you can try it or
don't ya I pizza was always better at
making sauces to me what's the point
every so often sad dominoes will just
tweet i'm sorry yes sorry people are fed
I'm sorry it's like my customers came in
they were also fat I'm so sorry so sorry
hashtag sad I delivered I delivered a
pizza meant for four people to a family
of six because that's all they could
afford I'm sorry oh man there was a java
or know that it was dong is he's just
talking about his delivery job and at
one point he touches on the sadness of
like delivering food to a guy who
immediately yells foods here and like in
full knowledge that no one was there oh
just busy the load with nobody's food to
my god so it's early on a Monday morning
this is this is the first step of game
yet yeah we really good but we're in the
game we're in a man we need like a quest
world montage like what it was like like
our [ __ ] it's becoming 3d you know like
get Jack into questworld should we and
then race Bannon I'm wondering should we
still should we have some mood music for
this oh yeah I mean if you have some
kind of serene I have an idea of doing I
have an idea for like a good soundtrack
for this okay all right let me let me
pipe this up let me get let me get the
speaks oh [ __ ] for those of you playing
along at home aaron is currently rifling
through a bag it's on the floor just
beyond a table with a big arrangement of
glass grapes on top he's removed a
cylinder that's right folks not a square
knot a rectangle a cylinder with a
shoelace around it it's a whole sleeve
onto it it's got this it's got to sleep
around the plastic seven so the shoelace
it was just like you
to hold the sleep on we're being
informed that it's to hold the sleeve on
sleeve is removed sleeve is removed and
now we are opening the cylinder opening
the chrysalis inside of which the
cylindrical speaker is contained is held
safe and sound I love that like bongo
noise let me check ninety percent charge
oh hell yeah that's not lastest bit
that's like almost a hundred percent
charge let's see uh we are going to go
we're going to go down yeah a nice kind
of like yeah it sounded like a good idea
in my head it's nice moody it's a borin
enter club of gore truth which is an
ambient a very moody ambient jazz band I
believe they are from the Germany oh the
Germany and this is their album sunset
mission okay I read a study today
suggested that you know avid fans of
jazz are among the more open find of
this music listener well I mean I think
that comes from just the fact that young
one jazz was always kinda like outsider
music just because it started in you
know black communities and two because
jazz not like an older style of music so
I I guess it largely stems from just you
know you got to be into older stuff to
be into jazz you got to kind of go out
of your way to absorb jazz in this day
and age yeah i think it was like indie
was number one jazz was too huh and then
pop was the lat like pop was the lowest
well yeah because pop is like you don't
have to you don't have to stretch
yourself to listen to pop music is
already everywhere is true so it is
early on a monday morning or a bid
twenties human being [ __ ] that's me you
have a significant other named alex who
you are rather fond of that you have
been seeing exclusively for the
past few months of [ __ ] the rest of your
social circle consists of a variety of
friends and acquaintances some of whom
you met at your day job which is a
little boring but pays the rent you'd
like to be doing more with your life as
with your parents but you're still in
the process of figuring out what that
means and how to go about it dude you
are also dealing with motivation issues
that sometimes makes dealing with these
things difficult you feel like this is
probably your fault and on bad base can
feel inwardly angry and down on yourself
for being lazy but you're not quite sure
how you can break out of it or how other
people deal with these feelings and seem
so very functional you spend a lot of
nights fixating on thinking about this
but never seem to do anything about it
other than lose sleep well this is
hitting close to home well is it made
it's an unreasonably warm Wednesday
evening you've spent the past several
hours at work the past week or so you
found your job motivation flagging more
so than usual you've been in a fog
practically all day today simply going
through the motions without realizing
even what you've been doing half the
time and yet times seem to be moving at
half speed you're you're so checked out
that when your boss approaches you to
tell you that it's dead and you can go
home early it barely registers as you
walk home the streets hissed for the
recent rainfall you know that your
significant other will be in classes
until late another couple hours at least
you briefly consider using the
serendipitous solitude to catch up on
that project that you've been working on
haphazardly for the past few month as
soon as you think about the work that
awaits you at home you can feel the
panic creeping in from the back of your
brain unbidden all you can think about
is how incredibly far behind you are and
the amount of work seems nothing less
than n surmountable ouch man sees this
is deep by the time you arrive home and
change out of Europe uncomfortable work
clothes the stress is weighing down on
you like a heavy wet wool blanket your
computer seems to be staring you down
from your desk you want to sit down and
work but the mere thought of trying to
work sends your stress levels flying
more than do anything you feel
only and absolutely exhausted and feel a
strong desire to simply hide in bed and
now we have our first choice do you or
one is crossed out so it's not an option
is not an option order some food grab a
drink and hunker down for a night of
work not an option off the table number
two will actively sit down at your desk
and try to make yourself do something
three turn on the TV telling yourself
you just need a quick half hour to
unwind from work for crawl into bed
you're so stressed and overwhelmed you
couldn't possibly accomplish anything
anyways you're depressed interaction is
exhausting and you are becoming more and
more withdrawal you are not currently
seeing a therapist who are not currently
taking medication for depression so oh
[ __ ] um Oh witch whose adventure do we
choose um or do we like I feel like
number two could go really badly because
it's like suddenly you'll just get
frustrated and not actually crank
anything out but number three could also
end badly because you could just end up
rotting in front the TV for way more
than a half hour okay so I must we're
supposed to answer these like what would
I honestly do or what is the best
strategy like am I going to try and win
this game um I was like if I'm answering
honestly it's like I feel like I would
attempt to and it would turn into three
uh if I was gonna answer honestly i
would say i would attempt i would want
to attempt to but it would turn into
three in that same way because rather
than it being the TV would be [ __ ]
around on the internet exactly so it's
like me Neal distraction yeah it's like
you sit down think I'm gonna crank this
out and then you get absorbed into other
things on the internet so I feel like
see the last thing I ever do is crawl
into please just go to sleep yeah it's
always like I'm going to be awake or
ever yeah because you know i'll be the
ultimate lazy if i sleep yeah cuz like
number four just number four just feels
like too much of a
surrender yeah so you're always very
reluctant to attempt to just dive right
into number four I guess we go in for
number three then yeah I think number
three all right number three turn on the
TV just a half hour of TV you tell
yourself absently grasping for the
remote you don't so much sit down on the
couch as sink into it you're on the TV
and start going through your usual
channel routine after a few cycles of
this realize you're really not doing
much more than thumb calisthenics and
absently killing time you check the
clock and see that over 20 minutes have
already passed since you sat down as
your self-imposed time clip time limit
creeps ever nearer you become more and
more anxious you stand up and walk to
the fridge telling yourself all just
make a quick sandwich and get to work
after that can't be productive on an
empty stomach right as you start pacing
around your apartment heading past your
bedroom in the process you stopped in
the doorway as it physically unable to
cross the threshold familiar ways of
exhaustion start racking you and you
feel simultaneously tired and panicked
you close your door and head back to the
couch it's still literally yet so you
tell yourself as long as I get to work
in an hour I'll have plenty of time to
be productive as you flip channels and
let the CSI in jeopardy reruns wash over
you you sink deeper into the couch
feeling at once encroached upon and
shielded by being quite literally
swallowed up by it as the second hour
draws nearer sure enough you find
yourself getting anxious and jittery you
were you repeat the fridge paste couch
process a couple more times before you
look at the clock and realize that
several hours have passed and not
surprisingly you've managed to get no
work done you crawl into bed acutely
aware of the fact that you have work in
the morning and that any opportunity you
had to catch up on your own creative
endeavors today have was squandered
you're feeling so disgusted with
yourself that when Alex calls to talk to
you on her way home from class you
simply say that you had a really rough
day of work and you're trying to rest up
before your shift tomorrow she says she
understands and wishes you a good night
that you can't help but notice she
sounds slightly disappointed ironically
the stress of pretend of potentially
upsetting your partner compounds with
expressive not having gotten anything
done this evening
stress of having to go into work
tomorrow the buzzing of anxiety and your
brain melts together with your body's
utter physical exhaustion and you sink
into a semi if magog akanksha spunk too
tired to try and work but too anxious to
fall asleep for several hours you are
very depressed you spend a large amount
of time sleeping hating yourself and
have very little energy or motivation
you are not currently seeing a therapist
or not currently taking medication for
depression sighs sidebar yeah I just
want to like record like a 12-minute jam
called semi hypnagogic looks just funk
yeah like in create a create a new genre
SF night if semi hypnagogic anxious [ __ ]
yeah just say would be it would be out
there but it would be it would be funky
I feel like King lizard in the king
gizzard in the Lycians gizzard and
lizard wizard I think that is semi semi
hypnagogic anxious Punk I'm so that's
the genre they're not neo psychedelic
their sadness emma hypnagogic anxious
funk we've cracked it and I'm so happy
down referenced king gizzard and lizard
wizard yeah that's their genre I'm so
happy we discovered her there Sean
raised so how you king gizzard fans all
you geezers it's a mild Friday afternoon
Alex calls you from one of her classes
telling you that there's going to be a
quote really awesome birthday party
tonight at her apartment that one of her
roommates is throwing you've hung out
with this room in a few times with Alex
and you get along well enough but you
aren't particularly close you don't have
work in the morning and have nothing
else in particular to do tonight you're
feeling kind of rundown but you have
been fatigued most of the time lately
you mentioned that you're feeling ill
because you're not sure how else to
explain those feelings to someone else
and say that you aren't sure you can
make it tonight there's a second of
silence over the phone but you but you
can swear you can hear the sound of your
partner's face fall she tries to
convince you anyway you haven't seen her
this week and she sounds pretty insisted
that you come over she even drops a few
suggestively worded hints thing
you can stay with her oh uh stay over
with them tonight after the party what
do you do and again the first option is
not on the table number one is shake off
your funk and go have a good time with
your girlfriend not often not an option
to agree to go three say that you're
really just not feeling well and can't
make it I would agree to go I would
agree to go to because I've just in my
situations just like a little bit of
social interaction has helped yes for a
little bit and it's usually like a
little bit of social interaction helps
and then on my end of things to it's
usually like well at least I did
something for somebody which in some way
kind of feels like i did a thing you
know you know productive st. and saying
that you're not feeling well and can't
make it at that point it's like you're
creating something you didn't do that
you can hope that you will later feel
bad about do about not doing yeah very
rarely does anybody feel like I should
have just stayed home unless something
absolutely terrible happens yeah you
don't think I should have just stayed
home yeah I mean usually in that
situation worse come towards your second
it was fine like yeah I was a psych
whose finds number to agree to go pretty
good final answer regis you agree to go
even though you're really not feeling
social you know it's important to alex
and you really like to see her seeing
her does make you feel better sometimes
and you hope that this is the case
tonight even if it does mean dealing
with all the usual social anxiety the
time to leave rolls around and grab your
overnight bag Alex's apartment is the
short walk away and there are already
people hanging out on the porch the
feeling your chest tighten as you
approach the building and try to steal
your nerves you quickly find your
partner chatting away with the birthday
girl and I was immediately lightens up
when she sees you I'm so happy you came
I wasn't sure you were going to make it
a young man taps around the shoulder and
she turns back to you to apologize and
let you know they have something they
have to do something for the party Alex
hands you a beer in plants a kiss on
your cheek before going off to deal with
whatever came up
as you look around you don't see anyone
else you recognize number one
enthusiastically socialize with an
exclamation point which you can't do
totally crossed out so number one is
just always off the table yeah number
two awkwardly stand in the same spot
unsure of what else to do three put your
bag in Alex's room and avoid the crowd
in there for 14 cling to the back walls
that you're being way for your
girlfriend to return 5 proceed to drink
in earnest hoping it makes you less
uncomfortable um I would probably move
yeah i would probably I can move
probably four yeah I know there was a
time when I would have done five not
because like not just because you know
it's like feeling a little bit loose
yeah it helps um I am NOT an alcoholic
no yeah but but you know I mean if you
find yourself in a social situation like
that where you're like cam here I might
as well kind of you know engage yeah um
three to me sounds like a smart idea you
know it's like you know it's like oh
there's something I you know it's like
I'm uncomfortable if I'm uncomfortable
in the room with all the crowd of people
then it's like oh well I have something
I have to do so let me do the thing I
have to do I have to put my overnight
bag in the room that I'm going to be
saying it that's the thing i'll have to
do and if I after I do the thing I have
to do then I can engage in the party
yeah um so what do you think oh um yeah
my J that would depend head depend on
how i'm feeling in this situation yeah
how just how much i do or don't want to
socialize like I'm very overwhelmed I
would probably go with three yeah but
usually I'm not as much in that place
yeah so what do we do like rock
rock paper scissors yeah it's also three
is like it's it's avoid the crowd in
there for a while because but I guess in
my situation would just be oh I would
just put the bag in yeah take a breath
maybe and then go back out not just like
I'm gonna just sit on the bed with the
door closed and just have a moment of
quiet before you know as long as I can
yeah it's like I wouldn't spend five or
ten minutes there I might sit down for a
second all right let's go like yeah some
so you want do for that would be that's
my most honest answer everything yeah
clean to the back wall zip your beer and
wait for your girlfriend to return yeah
cuz that's like your I mean in essence
you're making yourself act like you're
comfortable yeah you're going through
the motions of being comfortable plus I
mean you think so that you're
eliminating the whole feeling of oh I'm
so it feels so awkward to be here I'm
you know it's like I'm in this party I
don't know what I'm doing here it's like
out there at the very least like going
through the motions of being nonchalant
gives you kind of like this the prod
into the actual nonchalant this yeah so
for cling to the back wall zip your beer
and wait for your girlfriend to return
yep as Alex leaves you are not quite
sure what to do with yourself standing
in the middle of the room leaves leaves
you feeling kind of exposed and you
don't feel ballsy enough to randomly
approached any of the groups of people
clustered together talking you had to a
clear spot on the back wall and lean
against it for some reason this is
always this always feels a lot more
secure you scan the party for a familiar
face for any sign of your partner and
come up with nothing not sure what else
to do and worrying that you must look
creepy just standing there watching
everyone you take out your phone to busy
yourself 2020 semi tedious games of
bejeweled blitz later your partner
returns you spend the rest of the night
with Alex occasionally being introduced
to people and nodding along with the
group conversations even if you don't
participate that much at the end of the
night as you're falling asleep with your
girlfriend in the crook of your arm she
thanks you again for coming half drunk
she confides that she thought you were
going to flake out and was play
was surprised that you managed to come
out she says it lovingly but you're not
quite sure how you feel about that
statement next it's a little after noon
on a muggy Saturday we're good yet your
mother has come over for a surprise
visit claiming gladly she doesn't see
you enough so she decided to invite
herself over as you converse she walks
around your place you get the distinct
impression that you're being inspected
so what's going on with you lately she
asks abruptly taking someone aback by
this left fielder you tell her you're
not sure what she means she repeats the
question saying that you haven't seemed
like yourself lately she gestures to the
dirty dishes piled in the sink and notes
the fact that you haven't called or
visited in awhile your reticence only
seems to spur her on more she presses
you as if you're having problems at work
or with Alex and you're beginning to
feel increasingly battered by her sudden
well-meaning but overwhelming
Inquisition under her questions you
become increasingly uncomfortable you
want to be able to explain to her how
you've been feeling but the truth is
you're not really sure yourself nothing
horrific is happy that worker with your
significant other or friends or anything
like that but all the same you can't
deny that lately just felt drained and
as though they're not really here you
wish you could tell your mother these
things but she hasn't been approachable
about negative emotions in the past she
is the kind of person who holds the
opinion that the solution to any problem
is simply try harder and maintain a
positive attitude stands that has reared
its head and past conversations when you
begun to explore the subject with her
you know she's unlikely to be
understanding and you feel the energy
drain out of you when you imagine what
would happen if you manage to blurt out
everything you are feeling what do you
do number one not an option let her know
that you've been feeling down lately and
that you that you appreciate her concern
number two tried to be honest with her
anyway three tell her that everything's
fine and thank you for asking number
four change the subject
I'm a fine guy myself in these
situations i'm just like it's fine I
don't like I don't know I've become a
bit more open perhaps in recent year or
years yeah but I would at least before I
would always be like that it's fine
better yeah I I don't know I'm the guy
and this probably like branches often to
be like probably getting really [ __ ]
annoying but I'm the guy that thinks
well maybe they're like I'm always
thinking well maybe there's an angle to
actually explain this to somebody so
they had it maybe there is a way to get
somebody to get this yeah if I say it
right you know if I'm them is the right
sequence of word if I thoughts an idea
if I i if I'm strategic and judicious
with the way I spin this maybe I can get
the idea across you just need a powerful
yeah just a really sad power yeah who's
all those at our point well yeah
dollarboyz boy I want to do that I want
to like get a really shitty corporate
job to make power poison out of board
media show them a PowerPoint that just
gets sadder and sadder and gloomier and
greater and just like quarterly earnings
or what once the [ __ ] point what's the
point what's the point we're all gonna
die we're all gonna die yeah and just
are taking this [ __ ] with us I just
point everyone in the rooms like you
can't take your [ __ ] you can't take
your q3 returns with you you're gonna be
dead soon can't take that cool car
you're losing your stupid beach house
your beach house will one day get
swallowed by the ocean yet it will be a
rotting mass that dead coral will be
attached to when all the solid but like
rock and dirt matters corroded by an
unrelenting co2 our point to our point
Mike Mike Mike Rowe said our micro sad
dour point in Excel ya know Excel would
be just renamed to
coming up shores yeah actos good and
we're word would be mumble out of
Microsoft Outlook Outlook is do I
thought outlook is my dad is just called
still called outlook but it's got a sad
face in 20 yeah exactly it's just got a
much more dour look or sad looking a
icon yeah [ __ ] okay so what do we do for
this one try to be honest anyway um you
want to roll with that sure why not okay
a number to try to be honest with her
anyway you attempt to tell your mother
how you're feeling despite initial
misgivings that you have about doing so
finding the right words for how you're
feeling feels like trying to untangle
Christmas lights searching for the dead
bulb in the cluttered mess she watches
you intently inaudibly sighs before you
can clearly articulate anything
unfortunately she reacts predictably an
attitude like that won't get you
anywhere you need to work harder at
getting what you want instead of sitting
around and feeling sad about it nothing
good will happen unless you make it
happen she's an angry or spiteful as she
tells you this you try to explain that
it's not a matter of that but you can
tell that you're not really getting
anywhere the frustration chokes the
words in your throat and you give up on
trying to push the subject further you
know she's giving you the advice that
makes sense to her and genuinely wants
the best for you however she doesn't
understand that it's not this a simple
sub it's not as simple somehow deciding
to be positive or work harder it's that
those things aren't viable options
because of these feelings you accept
your defeat in the conversation drips to
other subjects she leaves after uh
chiding a chai tea yeah I have not seen
this word in my life have I not seen
this word of my way try to yeah I don't
know I don't know alright well she
leaves after chiding you to call her
more often and take better care of
yourself you sigh heavily as you close
the door behind her
spend the next few hours laying in bed
staring at the ceiling I feel like no
matter what this was never gonna go well
but if there was a way to win the game
better I feel like your options was
probably more on the money well you know
side note i'm very glad my mom is not
like that yeah exactly like very glad I
don't have that mom might yeah me
neither it's like my mom is usually
pretty understanding that these sorts
things and then willing to engage yeah
I'll you my dad gets that stuff pretty
pretty well considering your dad is an
interesting cat yeah my dad my dad is
eclectic the morning becomes your dad
exactly lazy Sunday wake up in the late
afternoon depressed as hell that's how
I'm doing so I'm really not gonna do
much yeah if you thinking what I'm
thinking sit on the couch and try not to
cry you think of what i was thinking
sleep during the day and forget to eat
spin my wheels and exhaust myself trying
to attempt to getting anything done
today hell yeah you figured what I'm
thinking shaming myself internally for
doing nothing but tread water my entire
adult life misshapen it hey folks we got
to take a quick sad break to to dry our
eyes but join us in part two for more
dank ass depression quest and remember
you too can prevent depression fire so
you can you two can prevent sadness
players who sounds like something you
would use in a video game is sadness
flares yeah that would be imagine a
video game where you have control over
other people's emotions and that's how
you that's how you engage in combat that
would be fascinating that would be the
more like okay we're getting carried
away with the sci-fi elements of this
like yeah I now I can make you really
self-conscious then use it as a weapon
I'll be actually very interesting yeah
okay the game I imagine it would be like
it would be like a mirror's edge type
thing where where it's like we're
specifically giving you a combat style
that does not
involve guns we're going out of our way
to give you that it could be very
telling if handled properly yeah so I'm
gonna go get program ya goin billion
dollar idea I'm going to go in game the
game big concept a concert iOS on the on
on dang can John I was the undec engine
the undec engine tank three